ukraine's capital has once again become
a target
a young woman rushed to an ambulance is
said to be a russian citizen
trapped under the crushed concrete for
hours
the body of her husband a ukrainian was
found nearby
a cruise missile hit their apartment
block around 6 30 in the morning
destroying every home
rescuers found their seven-year-old
daughter in the rubble alive but what a
thing to happen to such a young life
keebs mayor who visited the scene found
it no coincidence the bombing came on
the eve of a week of international
summits
before right now the
summit nato they attacked it's maybe
symbolic here it's more like aggression
in
the religious days
it's a symbolic attack
it's not the first time civilians have
been hit here an apartment block next
door was bombed in april when the u.n
secretary general was visiting the city
a military depot in the area has left
civilians who live here very vulnerable
it certainly doesn't appear that this
apartment block was the intended target
and while people here and kiev have
begun to enjoy more of a sense of
normality sense of safety in recent
months this just goes to show that they
live with the ongoing threat and ongoing
fear that this could happen at any time
nowhere is safe from russian aggression
a nursery playground nearby was hit in
the same attack
a crater smoldering next to toys
smashed windows framed by colorful
murals
mercifully a sunday no children were
there
residents living next door showed us in
to see their blown out windows
it's my life
my life is not good
the physical damage is obvious but
living with the threat of an attack is
clearly taking a psychological toll
below
within hours teams are clearing glass
from the surrounding area
[Music]
the response has become rapid and
routine not dissimilar to the attacks
themselves
[Music]
russian forces moved east a fragile
humdrum of life has returned to keeve
but residents know it can still all be
shattered in an instant
sally lockwood sky news